.
Freunde der Sonne,
ich stoße an meine Grenzen.
Bzw. ich habe jetzt
meine Grenze erreicht.
Ich will euch
kurz darüber aufklären,
wie es mir körperlich geht,
wie es mir psychisch geht,
und wie es mit maiLab weitergeht.
Fangen wir an mit body.
Der 10. Schwangerschaftsmonat
steht ins Haus.
Falls dich das wundert,
ich wusste vorher auch nicht,
dass es einen
10.Schwangerschaftsmonat gibt.
Genau genommen
bin ich jetzt in Woche 36 von 40.
Und es ist nicht ungewöhnlich,
dass Babys auch mal zwei Wochen
vor dem berechneten Geburtstermin
kommen, d.h. in Woche 38.
Und d.h., shit is getting real,
Freunde.
In meinem Bauch lebt gerade ein
Mensch der etwa 45 Zentimeter lang
und etwa 2,5 Kilogramm schwer ist.
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt denkt,
das ist ja schon
ein bisschen Extragewicht,
dass man da mit sich rumtragen
muss, hold my Fruchtwasser.
Die Gewichtszunahme beträgt
über die gesamte Schwangerschaft
durchschnittlich 9-14 kg.
Unterliegt jedoch großen
individuellen Schwankungen.
Ja, Freunde, ich habe
bisher 17 kg zugenommen.
Und ich bin nicht groß.
Dabei mache ich
im Moment so viel Sport: Laufen,
Socken anziehen,
aufstehen.
Mit der Geburt wird man
schlagartig 5 kg los.
Das geht auf Fruchtwasser,
Baby und Plazenta.
Und man wird danach
auch diese Wassereinlagerungen los.
Das sieht man vor allem
an den Händen und Füßen.
Ich habe die ziemlich stark.
Das habe ich meinem erhöhten
Östrogenspiegel zu verdanken.
Meine Birkis habe ich schon
auf maximale Breite gestellt.
So sieht es aus, wenn ich versuche,
meinen Ehering anzuziehen.
Außerdem hab ich
derzeit ca.40 % mehr Blutvolumen
als vor der Schwangerschaft.
D.h., mein Herz macht auch Sport.
Das Schlagvolumen des Herzen
kann sich unter Geburt,
wenn es richtig losgeht, von vor
der Schwangerschaft ca. 4 l/min
auf bis zu 10 l/min erhöhen.
Respekt!
Außerdem ist mein Herz gerade quer.
Das Uterus-Wachstum führt
über einen Zwerchfell-Hochstand
zu einer Querlage des Herzens.
So viel zu
den körperlichen Updates,
psychisch gehts mir ziemlich gut.
Also ich bin extrem ungeduldig,
ich kann an kaum etwas
anderes denken als an dieses Kind.
Ich kann den Tag damit verbringen,
so rumzusitzen mit den Händen
auf dem Bauch und
mich treten zu lassen.
Und komischerweise,
je näher die Geburt rückt,
desto weniger Angst habe
ich auch vor den ganzen Schmerzen.
Das haben schon
viele Frauen hinbekommen.
Das kriegen wir auch hin.
Das einzige, worüber ich mir Gedanken
mache, ist tatsächlich maiLab.
Eigentlich sollte man
jetzt nicht an die Arbeit denken,
aber maiLab ist auch mehr als Arbeit.
Dieser Kanal
ist ja auch mein Baby,
ich habe den ja
von klein an großgezogen.
MaiLab ist meine Leidenschaft.
Es ist Freude, es
ist Überzeugung, es ist Herzblut.
Aber jetzt bin ich an einem Punkt,
wo ich keine Videos mehr machen kann.
Und wenn das Kleine
erst mal auf der Welt ist,
dann erst recht nicht,
zumindest für eine Weile.
Ursprünglich war der Plan, dass ich
ein paar Videos vorproduziere,
die wir während meiner Babypause
veröffentlichen können.
Aber wir haben es
einfach nicht geschafft.
Wir hätten es geschafft,
wenn wir Videos mit weniger Recherche
und Produktionsaufwand
gemacht hätten.
Aber das wollte ich nicht.
Also unser Rechercheaufwand ist
seit der Teamvergrößerung durch Lars
eigentlich größer geworden.
Das ist ja eigentlich gut,
denn ich möchte euch
das wissenschaftliche Niveau liefern,
wofür ihr auch abonniert habt.
Auch der Produktionsaufwand
ist größer geworden.
Wenn man zurückschaut,
sieht man das hoffentlich auch
an der Qualität der Videos.
Aber die Videos
sind auch länger geworden.
Und Dreh und Schnitt mache
ich immer noch alleine.
Und deshalb sitze ich hier,
in Woche 36,
wir haben
kein einziges Video auf Halde.
Und wir haben
eine monatelange Pause vor uns,
in der ich auch keine
Schwangerschaftsvertretung habe.
Und dieser Gedanke ist
natürlich ein bisschen scary.
Ihr wisst ja, Youtube-Algorithmus,
man soll ja eigentlich
keine längeren Pausen machen.
Man fragt sich natürlich schon,
ob man durch so eine lange Pause
all die harte Arbeit, die wir in
den letzten Jahren hier reinsteckten,
man die nicht einfach zunichte macht,
weil man im Youtube-Dschungel
völlig untergeht.
Wenn ihr im nächsten Jahr
unbedingt unsere Videos
wieder schauen wollt,
wenn wir wieder da sind,
kann es sein,
dass sie von Youtube nicht angezeigt
werden und ihr es nicht mitbekommt.
Aber ihr könnt uns unterstützen,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Also ich frage selten nach Abos,
nur, wenn ihr gern maiLab schaut,
und uns noch nicht abonniert habt,
könnt ihr das gerne nachholen.
Und dann, das geht jetzt an alle
Abonnenten, die Glocke drücken.
Ich habe das auf diesem
Kanal noch nie gesagt,
aber das ist ein Moment,
wo es sich lohnen würde.
Das Kind, seine Gesundheit,
meine Gesundheit,
das geht jetzt erst mal vor.
Davon möchte ich
alles abhängig machen,
aber deshalb kann
ich euch nicht sagen,
wann ihr wieder etwas
von mir hören werdet.
Vielleicht gibt es ein Update
in 1 oder 2 Monaten,
vielleicht hört ihr erst in
3 Monaten wieder was von mir,
oder in 4 Monaten.
Aber wenn ihr die Glocke
gedrückt habt,
bekommt ihr eine Notification.
Dann haben wir alle die Chance,
dass unser Comeback
nicht an euch vorbeigeht.
Denn so viel will
ich auch noch sagen,
wir kommen im nächsten Jahr
auf jeden Fall wieder,
und zwar, Freunde der Sonne, stockt
schon mal euren Tee-Vorrat auf,
ich werde mir
noch mehr Verstärkung holen,
wir werden im nächsten Jahr
mit einer Teamvergrößerung starten,
und mit ganz vielen neuen Ideen.
Ich glaube eigentlich,
dass diese Zwangspause
dem Kanal langfristig gut tun wird.
Weil wir werden dann
noch einmal richtig Power haben,
um euch noch besseren Content
zu liefern.
Also, wenn ihr uns über
die Pause hinweghelfen möchtet,
dann ist jetzt die Devise,
abwarten, Tee trinken und
mit Bauch auch nicht ganz einfach.
(singt)
# Drückt einfach die Glocke,
ihr habt nichts zu verlieren.
denn maiLab ist gut fürs Gehirn.
# Der Algorithmus
wird uns sonst ignorieren.
# Damit Dankeschön, auf Wiedersehen,
drückt einfach die Glocke.#
Also Freunde der Sonne,
passt auf euch auf.
Ich werde das hier sehr vermissen,
aber wir sehen uns bald wieder.
Bis dahin, ihr wisst Bescheid,
bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von funk (2019)